praying for a better year ahead
inokatushari could only manage to afford
the basics this new year
milk rice and bananas
life is very difficult now things are
very expensive
in previous years we celebrated the new
year but this time we can't do much
others in this crowded colombo
neighborhood echoed her plight
this family struggled to find the milk
they needed for this new year tradition
they say everyone is finding it hard to
make ends meet
that difficulty is what's brought
together these protesters to the
president's office
they denounced gotabe rajapaksa and his
government for failing the people
this government hit us a lot because
their corruption and all they have they
didn't do anything every time they they
wasted our money
we voted for them not expecting they
would be like this destroying the
country
prime minister mahinda rajapaksa the
president's brother says he's willing to
talk to the protesters they have refused
we've embarked on a massive program to
get over the current crisis we're facing
the president and the government is
spending every second to get our country
out of this crisis
[Applause]
for months government leaders insisted
they were in control of the economy but
on tuesday they announced the suspension
of international debt repayments until a
bailout plan is agreed with the
international monetary fund
sri lanka must put together the
deeper commitment to economic
plan
that gets the economy out of the mess
not just immediate emergency assistance
and also fix the political legitimacy
and stability problem because these two
now go together
protesters are showing little signs of
giving up they say that all communities
all races and religions have united
under the national flag to continue
their agitation for president gotabe
rajapaksa and his government to go home
they say they'll be here till that
happens
fernandez al jazeera colombo